hi everyone welcome to khan academy's
daily homeroom live stream for those of
you all who do not know what this is uh
this is something that we thought of
when we started seeing mass school
closures and we know that people are
going to be at home socially distanced
and obviously khan academy we saw
ourselves as you know it's our duty to
step up in this time of closures a lot
of our resources are the way that many
of y'all might be able to keep learning
or have your children or your students
keep learning uh but we've also been
trying to do other supports we thought
it'd be just fun to have a a synchronous
way to have interesting conversations
between each between ourselves to bring
on interesting guests from from from all
over the world on all sorts of topics i
am doing an interesting experiment today
that we should all have a growth mindset
about things i have my phone leaned
against my computer right over here so
that i can simultaneously do this on
instagram so normally we do we do we
have some technology that felipe has
found that allows us to do this on
facebook and youtube simultaneously but
now we have added instagram so i'm
saying hi to all of the folks on
instagram as well
so today's topic is going to be really
interesting it's going to be graduation
and life advice and you can almost view
this as like a interactive graduation
address which is frankly better than you
know just me sitting at a podium and
giving you something that you might not
remember for for the next 20 minutes uh
but before we break into the q a but
start thinking of those life advice
questions uh that you would like uh and
we have team members i'm going to be
looking at the instagram and then our
team members are going to be helping me
out with youtube and facebook i do want
to give a special thanks to several
corporations that have stepped up over
the last several weeks especially with
the covid crisis khan academy is a
not-for-profit we can only exist because
of philanthropic donations from folks
like yourself
and from corporations and foundations
and folks like bank of america
google.org at t fastlane of artists have
stepped up just in the last few months
when they realized that our costs were
going even higher because our our usage
our uh our server costs our our usage is
about two and a half three x of what it
typically is we're trying to accelerate
all sorts of programs forward uh so
thank you to all of them and once again
if you're in a position to donate every
dollar matters it helps us it shows a
show of confidence it helps us reach
that many more folks who otherwise would
not be able to have access to some form
of a free world-class education or or
teachers who would not have access to
tools like this so with that i would
love uh to take any questions uh that
you have and i already see a couple of
questions oh actually it looks like uh
my team is also scanning instagram so
this is this is super helpful for me
so
from instagram at srg underscore 19 asks
what is your favorite memory from high
school
you're taking me back all right let me
see i don't know if it's my favorite
memory but i could probably
think of some memories
um
i remember there was a a day
i was in in student council and we were
you know in student council in high
school you paint those you know those
pep rally type banners and stuff and
there was you know someone had forgot to
close the yellow paint
and
i kind of wanted to make a point that
like when you don't close the yellow
paint the yellow paint all dries up and
so i was like look this is all dry and i
did this and i was like look how dry it
is and then it wasn't dry and so i
the yellow paint that was a good memory
it helped me to take myself a little
less seriously
the universe was conspiring uh to keep
me from being too self-righteous uh
let's see other great memories from high
school i mean you know there's great
memories i remember we went on a camping
trip my senior year that was that was
great we kind of got lost so it's always
those memories where it's a little bit
of an adventure that's that's nice
um
there's some things i cringe at some of
you all may or may not know that uh you
know when i i did give the graduation
address at my high school graduation
and uh
i was a little bit angsty i was also uh
well by by my senior year i was not
in a band but my sophomore year i was a
lead singer in a heavy metal band and so
i i had that little angst in me and so
at graduation i i felt the need and i
cringe a little bit about it now but i
guess it is a memory uh to to kind of
make a statement so
the the morning of graduation my a
friend and my myself we we actually
snuck into the auditorium where the
graduation was going to happen
and we put a guitar under the diploma
table and so uh when i went up to give a
speech
i said i think it would be better if i
sang this
and so
i took the guitar out from underneath
the diploma table i still remember the
fate the look on my principal's face you
know it was just like horror
and frankly half the crowd but
and i sang
so
that's
that's i cringe on it now i wouldn't do
that today and i wouldn't recommend it
today uh but it was it was it was novel
um so i'll i'll think i'll try to think
of more and more memories uh as as as as
we go through this session but that's a
good question
so from instagram
marvelous asks how old were you when you
realized that helping others to learn
was a passion of yours
a great question
lean marvelous um
and if you see me looking back and forth
i'm looking at i'm looking at my
computer screen and i'm looking at the
instagram screen so that i'm you know
making eye contact with everyone uh so
you know i realized i really enjoyed
tutoring folks it was actually around
that same time in high school uh and
actually you know that even jogged some
other really great memories
but it might not surprise folks that i
was the captain or the the president of
the math club
high school it was called mu alpha theta
i don't know if that's a thing where you
go to where you go to high school uh but
as part of it we wanted to do service
and
we figured a valuable service would be
to tutor our peers and so we used to do
this after school tutoring thing for you
know our peers and a lot of kids
actually showed up for it and
it was then that i realized that if you
give students if you give your if you
give your anyone one-on-one attention
give them a chance to fill in their gaps
uh that that they're really capable of
learning you know almost anything and i
saw before my eyes a lot of my friends
or even people i didn't know who were c
students
who thought they weren't good at math
when they just got a little bit of
attention they were able to
catch up and
and do whatever they needed to do so
that was the first time i realized i
really enjoyed it then when i was in
college i did a little bit of that as
well
there was a local school had had budget
cuts and so they needed some more
i guess you could say volunteer teachers
or teacher assistants and so myself and
my roommate we went and volunteered this
was in brookline massachusetts and
really enjoyed it i realized that i had
no classroom management skills
a lot of you
a lot of you teachers can appreciate uh
how important that is i i didn't at the
time and you know i there were moments
where i had some fifth graders you know
standing on top of a table and i had to
spend a little bit more time than i'd
like telling them to get off uh but you
know i realized that that was intriguing
to me in in i think it was after my
junior year i got a fellowship
uh
to work on software uh i had applied for
it work on educational software for
students with attention deficit disorder
it was called an elerant fellowship at
my undergrad and uh that was the first
time i started writing some software and
seeing if this could be of of help to
folks
and then you know i
the life took over pragmatism took over
and uh graduating from college i had a
reasonable amount of debt and i said i
need to make some money maybe help help
out the family a little bit
so you know i went into tech which i
also enjoy my background my
undergraduate degrees were in math and
computer science
and uh and you know many of y'all know
the story i i then go to business school
i become a hedge fund analyst but then
while that was happening my cousins
needed help and so it kind of kindled
that same joy for the subject matter and
for
um being able to help folks especially
family members and so that's what got me
on the track and that you know the more
i did it the more that i saw gains in my
cousins and other folks that i knew and
frankly the more that i got letters from
random people on the internet saying
that it was helping them uh the more i
think you know i don't think there's
anything special about me i think anyone
would find that incredibly rewarding and
it was a little bit addictive uh you
really you start to realize how much
more joyful that is when you get a
letter from someone in indonesia saying
that you help them you know
get back to going to college versus you
know you get a slightly larger bonus at
your uh at your hedge fund job you
realize that maybe maybe this is what
you could what you could do for a living
so
you know it was just uh i guess you
could say signs that were showing up in
my life throughout and at some point you
just have to pay attention to those
signs they keep trying to make
themselves a little bit more visible
so let's see from instagram a lot of
questions from instagram we should do
this more regularly that you know
have have uh both live streamed all of
the above andy chavez oh it disappeared
said
how did you learn how do you learn from
failure
um oh there it goes how do you learn
from failure
so the
i think the
the first step is to just recognize that
the failure is not a
it's not a judgment on you i think so
many times we confuse ourselves with our
thoughts
with our labels that society is putting
on and things like grades or you failed
or you didn't that's kind of a label or
some extrinsic thing that happens to you
and to realize it's not yourself and to
realize that those are the moments of
growth the fact the very fact that
you're failing is a good sign it's not
it's a sign that you're pushing yourself
out of your comfort zone you're not just
kind of resting on your laurels and uh
and if you reflect on that failure and i
recently met a teacher who likes to use
the phrase fail forward so if you
reflect on that failure and you say okay
what can i learn from it so that maybe
next time i try i have a little bit
lower chance of at least failing in that
way
then i'm making progress that's how you
grow as a human being and you know this
mystery that we all live in call life
and it is really a mystery
uh you know
all i can think of the best thing to do
is just keep on
keep on going keep on growing keep on
failing and keep on learning from that
and when you do that and actually when
you learn when you see that you can get
onto the other side of failure even once
you know we i think it was we had
alberto carvalho who's superintendent of
miami-dade he said something about that
the first time that you do something a
little bit scary and it's you even fail
a little bit but then you power through
it and you realize that you can get to
the other side of it
that's that's when you realize that's a
muscle and then next time when you see
an obstacle and you see the failure
you're like well it's just going to be
like last time sure i might
try a little bit i might fail a little
bit but i just have to keep chipping
away at that thing and before i know it
i'm gonna i'm gonna be able to get
through it so that's the best advice and
actually there's a ton of research on
that that
that those who are willing to embrace
failure those who are willing to step
out of their comfort zone and learn from
it
who define themselves not by
the outcome by success or failure but
who define themselves by hey i'm someone
who's always willing to try i'm always
i'm someone who's always willing to to
do the hard thing those are the people
who do really well in life uh without
fail
not not to overuse the word
um
so
let's see from instagram
it's me shreyash asks how was your
graduation day
so actually you know i've i've had um
several graduation days high school and
then undergrad and then uh from from
business school
i would say you know i've already
described my high school graduation a
little bit i have to say graduation days
have been unusually eventful for me so
when i was in college
i was my senior class president at mit
and
so i was on the commencement committee
and at the time the president of the
united states was bill clinton and so
you can imagine when we used to have our
meetings for the commencement committee
this was you know in november of my
senior year this was in 1997
we had
these meetings like who should we invite
for commencement and the previous year
al gore had spoken and so you know i was
just like why don't we invite the
president of the united states
just thinking why not see see if the
president will show up
and uh you know the vice president
showed up the year before and and uh i
remember uh president vest who was the
president of mit at the time said sal
first of all there's no way the
president's going to show up second of
all it's a bit of a pain with the
security and all the logistics and
even though the vice president was
pretty tough the president would be even
harder so anyway i'm like all right you
know so we we actually did invite and uh
the that year's time man of the year was
someone by the name of david ho who
helped develop some of the antivirals
that helped kind of
cure aids so big deal time man of the
year was our commercial speaker i was
excited about that
and so uh you fast forward to about i
think it was like
three days before commencement
and i get a email from president vest
saying
sal are you okay with this and it was a
forward from the white house
and it said uh president clinton
would like to give a major
speech or whatever on the digital divide
at mit's commencement and he would like
he's inviting himself
to be the commencement speaker
and so i just responded back i was like
yeah i'm cool with this
and so uh
he ended up being our commencement
speaker with like a few days notice and
then it was literally oh no it was more
than that it was it was now that i
remember that email was actually
probably a few about a month before
commencement because obviously all the
logistics and then the night before
commencement was actually when i got the
other email from pres from president
vest saying are you okay with this and
it said that uh president clinton would
uh
has some time and might be coming an
hour early and would like to meet with a
few student leaders and so this was just
one of these random things where it was
like me and six other student leaders we
got to spend you know an hour with the
president united states in you know when
we you know
right before our graduation and you know
regardless of your political affiliation
regardless of anything
it's a pretty heady experience if you're
21 years old it's your graduation day
and the present united states wants to
hang out with you before graduation for
an hour and it really was kind of like
hanging out it was really weird uh in a
good way it was you know because you
normally think these
people are
you know some kind you know
you don't realize they're people too so
it's a fascinating conversation and then
you know right when we were all like
getting out of the door ready to go line
up for for commencement president
clinton says you know i think i have a
little bit of time after my speech i
would like to give a couple of student
leaders their diplomas and so
uh he kind of he gave you know i gave my
little you know two-minute speech as as
class president then president clinton
gave his digital device then david hoe
gave his so we had we had two
commencement speakers and then president
clinton gave me and three other people
our diplomas and then he got on his
helicopter and left
so
that was
i was like wow how did that happen uh
you know that it was it was definitely a
a powerful experience for me uh and you
know once again regardless of where you
are on the political spectrum regardless
of of anything
when you're when you're young and you
realize that you know there's these
people who have done
who are very influential in the world um
that they are still human beings and
that you can connect with them and talk
to them
it it did open my aperture it did make
me think okay wow you know maybe this
world
maybe this is a world in which
i too might have something to contribute
so you can't you can't discount
something like that so so that was a
a very a very powerful experience
so let's see
um
instagram que ando how did you feel
right after graduating from college
so this is an interesting question um
i i actually
you know there's there's a little bit of
excitement that you're graduating from
college that uh you know all those
problem sets and deadlines and all of
those things that that kind of college
academic rat race is a little bit over
but i have to you know in hindsight i
realized it was sad uh because
so much of your
identity your friendships they're all on
college at college and i was excited you
know i was going to move out to
california for a job at my first job was
going to be a product manager at oracle
and i was excited about that
but you know i didn't know anyone out in
northern california and so you know when
i came out here i have to admit it was
it was tough i you know i tell i tell a
lot of folks that first year out of
college going to a place where i didn't
know anyone i didn't have any really you
know good friends uh you know i spent a
lot of nights just hanging out at the
barnes and nobles you know reading books
for free that was kind of my my social
life it wasn't it wasn't the best year
for me it was it was a tough year um and
that slowly uh and you know what what
happened was i had a lot of friends who
we were with and and i i finished my
degree a little bit early so i came out
a year earlier and so when when more of
my friends came out the next year then i
started to get a little bit better but
that that first year out of college i
think it is it can be a little bit
jarring because i was fortunate i had a
a a good job i had a good boss i had
good co-workers but it's still not the
same thing as what you get when you're
you know in the dorm room uh you know
pontificating things doing silly things
that you you do in college you know
still when i get together with my
college friends we reminisce about
a lot of the silliness
that that happened in college so um
so so yeah it was tough but then slowly
but surely it it got better as more and
more friends you know and i met new
people
and it is all about keeping an open mind
to things uh to to new people and not
just you know um
grieving for for what you might have
lost and then you know but i was eager
to go back to business school because
business school had a little bit of that
element as well uh
you know just a sense of community etc
etc and then you know but after business
school by that point i had a fiance so i
was feeling less lonely
and so
i i you know post business school life
life felt pretty good uh and then i and
then she married me um
so instagram
aiden
jaffarova says what do you wish you
would have known when you graduated from
high school
i think
you know i i was a reasonably i i'm
fundamentally an introverted person like
if i go to a big dinner party and i'll
enjoy it but then i like to come home
and just
decompress and have quiet time for
myself that's when i re re-energize
and even when i went to college and
actually in high school as well i always
did have the mindset that hey you know i
want to step out of my comfort zone i
want to try new things i want to i want
to try to to meet new people and and be
open to things but i think especially in
high school and to a lesser degree in
college but especially in high school
it's very easy to get into your head and
saying oh well
you know
they probably don't really wouldn't be
interested in hanging out or you know
they're in that crowd i'm in this crowd
you know we're friendly but we wouldn't
really you know
we really wouldn't get a lot from each
other and and i think that's a mistake i
think you actually have the chance to
get the most from the folks in in your
in your high school and in your college
that are different from you
and
what i now realize in hindsight and i've
met many of these people now that we're
you know adults and
everyone has those same insecurities
everyone i don't care who it is it could
be the you know the the captain of the
football team the homecoming king queen
everyone's oftentimes some of them will
have more of those insecurities because
they're afraid you know their identity
is so defined by by some of these these
things these external things and so i
think if you're an open person who's
genuinely interested in other people
uh you can form deeper connections with
with all with anyone and they will
appreciate it and even at even you know
on first cut they might be leaving a
little bit weirded out i mean you know
you don't do things that are
truly you know scary or anything but if
you're like hey do you need anything hey
i want to help you um hey tell me about
your your family
at first people like why are people
asking why is why is he interested in me
but then people are like oh well you
want to know i'll tell you and
i think those deep connections are super
powerful i i think another thing that i
wish i knew better in high school is
that
you know it's easy to treat your
teachers as kind of teachers and only
teachers uh and i did form i would say i
would say friendship with a handful of
teachers uh you know mr hernandez miss
kennedy are the ones in high school that
definitely come to mind that i could
talk to about things and they would talk
to me about
you know stuff
it was really powerful i you know they
they treated me more like mike appear
and obviously sometimes they had to play
teacher and i was a student but a lot of
times there was a nice uh camaraderie
between us uh but i think you know
for for other times it was very easy to
say oh so and so that teacher is like
this they like to fail students and
they're like that and in hindsight i
realize how wrong it is because
99.9999 of the teachers that i had and
i'm sure you have
their number one priority was to try to
prepare you for the world and make you a
better human being and i wish uh and you
know as you know i told you the story of
me having a bringing a guitar to
graduation and
so you can imagine every now and then i
wasn't probably the easiest student to
have in your classroom uh
and and so
one of one of the things i wish i did
was also
uh
for for even some of the teachers that i
felt
uh were you know weren't aligned with my
worldview i wish that i i had reached
out to them more and figured out how i
could support them and also tell them
how much what they did meant to me and
to our peers and how much we we grew
from it i have to say even some of those
you know we have every every you always
have your your favorites and then you
have those teachers they're like oh
they're so hard and they're just trying
to stick it to us but i gotta tell you
when you're 40 42 43 years old like
myself i get together with friends i was
like you know that we learned a lot in
that class and so and so teacher really
by kind of being hard on us kind of
prepared us like prepared us for life
so
those are some of the things that i i
wish um
i had known and to just know that it all
works out it all it really all works out
that everything that you stress about in
the moment
usually a week later a month later for
sure a year later you won't even
remember what that thing was that you
were worried about um and i still remind
myself that because every now and then i
do have something where i wake up in the
middle of the night i'm like oh why why
is that happening and why and then i
remind us sal you've gone through this
like 500 times now
it's not going to matter
it's not going to matter in the long run
just do what you can be an open person
be an optimistic person and the universe
will hopefully
give you back some of that optimism and
openness as well and and things will
resolve themselves so those are some of
the things so you know some of the
stress was unnecessary and some of the
anxiety and some of the insecurities in
fact all of it was unnecessary
i wish i had meditated i started i
picked that up about two two years ago i
wish i had started even 10 minutes a day
because then all the stuff that i just
talked about wouldn't have it would have
just you know it's like it's like a
rain-x for your soul
things just beat up and fall off they
don't they don't absorb into your mind
um from instagram louisa
montevani asks hi sal what are tips to
decide what you want to study in
university
um
so
my advice is don't steer type yourself
too much i think it's very easy for us
you know sometimes we get a little
positive feedback from one teacher
another and one subject or another and
saying oh i'm a writer or i'm a
programmer or i'm a math person and they
say i'm going to be a writer or i'm
going to be an art historian because of
that feedback and that might be the case
and those might all be great fields but
i think you know it depends we're going
to the uh where you go to school but in
the u.s you know there's a lot of
opportunity to try things especially
your freshman year so i would take
courses in in a pretty varied
thing i would i would you know the other
thing i wish i knew is a lot of
professors don't mind it you know i used
to think hey there's 200 kids in this
room
the professor has no interest talking to
me but
i wish i had at least tried and you know
sometimes i did talk to the professor in
smaller classes but in those large
classes i was always like oh
i'm just gonna go do my thing they don't
but oftentimes you could talk to them
especially if you're genuinely
interested you know there's some
students who are not generally
interested and they're just trying to
kind of suck up to the professor to
maybe get an a
but but there are also students who are
genuinely interested in if you are
genuinely interested in the course and
the subject matter the professor will
like will probably want to talk to you
and might even have an internship for
you or have advice about it for you and
so i would do that
i would talk to as many people i would
talk to as many upperclassmen as you can
find ask them as many questions
especially the upperclassmen the seniors
who are getting jobs
ask sometimes you know a little bit
sensitive questions how much you're
getting paid what is the job offer what
does the job market look like in that
major um and then if you can find to get
a hold of alums uh you know people who
graduated the last few years because
it's one you know sometimes the major
the work that you do in the major is
different than the work that you do in
the job
um and so talk to the alums who majored
in x and say okay you got a job
i don't doesn't hurt to ask them how
much money do you get paid how hard you
have to work what's you know all of that
but then ask you know what is the actual
work like what surprised you about it
what didn't surprise you about that work
and um
you'll learn a lot i i have to say you
know if there's one thing that and i
didn't do it well early on but by my
junior and senior year in in in college
and for sure my
my second year in business school that's
what i did i was very shameless i would
i would you know i remember i really
enjoyed a capital markets class which is
all about the stock market and the bond
market and how money moves to the
through the world
and you know it was a pretty math heavy
class and um and and in business school
you know i went to business school
at hbs you know it wasn't you know the
math a lot of students didn't go super
deep in the math and so i i oftentimes
was the closer so to speak where the
professor would say sal how do we solve
this equation and so i used so i got i
had a good relationship with that
professor his name was george choco and
i said george you know i love this class
what what
what can i do in life that is like this
class
and he said well you should go work at a
hedge fund and i said that sounds
awesome what is a hedge fund
then he explained it's like it's like a
mutual fund but they can do more exotic
things
you know they can kind of they have more
flexibility in how they invest but
they're regulated differently so i was
like okay that's interesting and then i
looked at all my classmates who had
worked in finance and then i started
going i was like what's a hedge fund how
much do you get paid what's the
lifestyle like and i was like oh
this sounds good at least to me and then
i started going through the the job
search process so that wasn't picking
the major but i was picking kind of the
career but the same process is true on
the major side just ask a ton of
questions don't be afraid to ask about
money sometimes on university campuses
money can kind of be viewed as a little
bit of a gauche sub oh we're academics
how dare you talk about career and money
no talk about money
money for sure isn't everything in life
but
uh you need to be able to you know put
food on the table support yourself pay
off your debt if you're if you're not
able to do that kind of stuff
you're not going to be able to do the
high-minded stuff
so i'm not saying you have to become a
millionaire or even have to become you
know affluent but it's super important
to think about am i picking a major that
i have a decent chance of getting a job
that i enjoy
uh you know not just tolerate but i can
enjoy and i can pay off my debt and have
a reasonable chance of you know saving
for a down payment on a house and uh you
know one day and you know being able to
go on vacations and you know if i choose
to have a family to to send my kids to
college in the future so i don't think
it's ever too early to think about that
all right so
i these are great maybe we'll do another
one of these uh you know whenever we
don't have a guest uh maybe this will be
graduation season because i'm you know i
don't know if y'all i i'm enjoying
playing uncle sal right now
so this is
um
this is so
youtube first guy gomez asks what would
you have done differently if you could
start college over again
you know it's the same and i'll finish
on this because i just realized i think
i do have a a a call that i can't
reschedule starting like a minute ago um
if if i could start college over again
it's the same advice that i said i would
be that much more open i would be you
know if i'm thinking if if someone has
helped me if they mean something to me i
would have told them that i would have
stepped out of my comfort zone that much
more and i did step out of my comfort
zone you know when i was uh my freshman
year in college i intentionally joined
the improv comedy troupe because i was
like there's nothing like stepping out
of your comfort zone like improv comedy
and we had to travel around from school
to school and you know people would
shout out a noun a verb a setting and
you know context and you'd have to kind
of act it out and try to be somewhat
humorous uh
so there's nothing like improv comedy
that will uh teach you to be out of your
comfort zone but i would have done more
of that and and i would have
you know i would have been more open
with my thoughts my emotions my
insecurities because that's the type of
thing that forms the deeper con the
connections deeper friendships and i
came out of college with great uh
friendships uh and i feel very fortunate
for it i met my wife in college uh
but i i think there could have been even
more uh and even to this day you know i
probably every once a month i probably
have a dream about college where i'm in
you know one of these circumstances a
lot of it's like the end of the term and
i forgot to drop a class and i'm like oh
my god you know whatever
but anyway uh thanks everyone for being
part of this i think this kind of worked
out doing the instagram and the and the
facebook and youtube at the same time
and i just want to want to thank
everyone everyone for joining this and
i'm going to go jump onto that call now
see how do i turn this
you